well happy bro happy Monday
my flight was canceled as you know think
that one's ever ever ever ever report
dental weather
yeah well it's fun cuz you get there as
snow on I'm on my flight I'm all set
it's 12:40 and they go well late and
gentlemen we're out on a little trouble
with the tail a little sensor on the
tail okay oh my god yeah that's cool
reality we're gonna get out there and
fix it oh we can't get up there right
now cuz the wind the wind so I'm like
what then the guy goes I got a new plane
in here oh that's cool how long well six
fifteen twelve fourteen Appaloosa get in
take a seat for the next five hours
oh alright then he'll go for a hike man
I can't do that so do that and then I'm
waiting getting on my plane planting
land in five minutes ladies and
gentleman circling the airport
oh well it's circling there's nothing
wrong I get this I literally want to
jump I get this I'm like I can't wait to
get [ __ ] home come on because I want
to see my kids too you know
and I get this I get well I spoke too
soon ladies and gentlemen unfortunately
the winds are not allowed on the plane
to land and it is turning back and going
to Salt Lake City so no but she's what I
died yeah nobody was good you literally
just wanna like yeah I'll put you on a
middle seat on United at 9:30 in the
next morning if you'd like oh is that
the best you can do that so you
literally wanna die
just dying let me [ __ ] pour this pour
it in laughs hey I got to see hey shut
up no you shut up you definitely shut up
about dude [ __ ] game of Thrones god I
can't wait
johnny-come-lately we were watching this
show for eight years and now you're
you're walking with a t-shirt it says
King Slayer the [ __ ] guy he's new to
the game it's like dubbed a rock when he
first got an iPhone we don't have one
for 10 years it's like these iPhones are
great are they are they oh do you see
that so lovely yeah by the way you
didn't by the way this this season so
far can kiss my ass all three episodes
no she should fight scene I like to
fight too wow I thought I was amazing
all right two fights I thought it was so
well the whole shows that spicy yeah I
like especially their most expensive
production of all time on TV absolutely
also the most-watched episode ever in TV
history if you have our billion people I
haven't felt it I gotta be home saying I
was just you know I'm so good I was
emotional I was the best thing I've ever
seen
you [ __ ] best thing I've ever said
you guys shut up man I like the fever's
you too ha targets to drivers dude are
we watching your photo by the way by the
way my TV 4k amazing at a 4k everybody
don't dark too [ __ ] dope and
everything your teammates been
complaining no they have it just trolls
if you complain about episode 3 you
cannot be my friend the best thing I've
ever seen you're out of your [ __ ] you
are what's better I'll enjoy it what's
better everything else whatsoever on
better than that you'd say it's good
don't get carried on like that I've ever
seen with your weaponry the guy who's I
gotta watch shows with dragons now he's
jogging the balls deep I know you are
yeah no [ __ ] don't believe you watch
cannot wait yeah I've been watching you
since day one it's so good it's a great
just so good why are you hating on it I
a little bit I was how people hate not
at first it's hilarious - episode you're
that good guy yeah yeah it was so good
it was so amazing and there was so much
hype going into it for them to the liver
was in say I have disagree on that
that's crazy man I know I just didn't do
it for me dude
my god I thought it was so good I mean
the climax of how it ends I was like you
saw that coming I just - are you really
yeah what show every show where all of a
sudden the bad guys like then you know I
don't want to give everything away but
oh you're [ __ ] break down your
audition for a [ __ ] to roll away
that's what happened sir he's supposed
to be a white Walker like an extra I'm
Jon Snow I'm John Surratt is so good Jon
Snow
oh my god guard though the White Walkers
I thought it was so good I know you did
dude oh I'm aware I'm aware that you
like this is Kansas Slayer its
Kingslayer you know what the [ __ ] that
is
King Slayer bro you walk in with your
King Slayer shirt King's lair dude I
might choose King Slayer and some fan
sent you don't send Brendan G ot
paraphernalia please oh they do alright
drugs and [ __ ] I get also don't send
them drawing ifs they send me these
little characters now you get a bunch of
those you get you get all kinds of
trinkets and gifts and I get [ __ ] cuz
your old dude what did me because I'm
old you know I got a post about it you
don't know you know you're not doing
anything you don't know maybe I would
they don't
um so they don't who's your favorite
character in G ot oh I like them all man
I've heard you know I don't have
favorites listen bro you are so I love
[ __ ] annoying
give me your favorite right now now man
okay I love them all Tim Ken except I
spoil this episode for him he's gonna
fly cuz he's on tour some [ __ ] killing
people said if I spoil it for him he's
gonna skin me alive and wear my body
it's good wear your skin I was like dude
well alright yeah it's a town show the
first time I met Tim he showed us how to
kill a send me with a knife uh using
Evan Todd
Daenerys is so [ __ ] hot doesn't do it
for me I'm not talking about Game of
Thrones with you just do it for you that
hotter off to me oh I like the other one
I like you like Jon Snow cuz you're a
gay man no I like oh I like I like the
red the red priest Allah fire
she's so the flower girl he must be a
huge fan fire lady and Sansa I think
sounds like you like I like the redhead
yeah oh they kind of kill me um but
brands talking I wonder where they go
from here though like meaning like well
now that was so insane now they have to
battle it out there's still a battle to
be won for the Circe's but yeah I'm
assuming because no one really died in
this way oh you're spoiling yeah no it's
art it's out that's it this what you're
on Tuesday dude oh okay but don't you
still hey Milly billion people watch
this know what spoiling anything now if
I did it yeah but yesterday you don't
want Tim to wear your skin he's like
he'll have to do the podcast and I'll be
where he's not gonna listen
he'll be it'll be Tim and Brennan's skin
yeah it's just it was so like there's so
much hype in this episode and then now
you have three left yeah only three I
thought it was only three only six six
total I thought it's eight for sure six
total you how six it is interesting to
see how they've grown up how small she
was how Anya Stark was I know eleven
years old you know oh I think about this
also interesting when they went like so
that ISIL that obviously making Bank but
like she's always gonna be Sansa you
know like when you get out like your
label back oh yeah I can tell you yes
like think it like think about the epic
shows like like Jeremy pivens always
you're Ari Gold no matter what you do
your ego old bro it may name any other
show that's major like that like you
like Courtney Cox you don't think you've
heard anything besides for it
Jeff Ranson you're you're Rachel bro all
right Jennifer Aniston had a hell of a
movie career though after yeah but still
you still most people know is Rachel um
the the a Leblanc
well I all I think about no you know
what you know what you know what you and
I would hate to do you want you know
what you and I would hate more than
anything
believe it or not shooting this show
being on the show when I watch the show
from what I know about shooting TV and
movies I when I think of the costumes
and makeup and the sad
and the amount of moving parts you spend
so much time standing in one place and
waiting for your shop that you love
those to be on the biggest show of all
time I'll chew at the shot stop trust me
no but it feels like that does not my
passion yeah it was my passion I would
shut the [ __ ] up yeah you and Playa why
do you do but you spend a lot of time
doing that
trust me yeah but that's the game that's
the same outfit with all kinds of stuff
yeah some people love that for me yeah
but some people they love it yeah 100
percent not if that's your passion just
not I bet you'd be stoked to be on Game
of Thrones and I ain't character I'd
have to be drunk all the time
come on go back go back to that go back
to that that's that's all day long stand
there all day long it's just little
details like that the factor no in it I
hate it oops
I mean that kind of stuff it's not so
quit acting on school no that I like
because I like all the people yeah a
little makeup in my hair
yeah what you saying light now you're
just constantly being be on the base of
all the details
the details are it's not how it feels
when you're doing it I'm not saying they
don't have a blast they don't love each
other and they're all great people and
they are doing something you're super
negative thing huh we're SEP so it over
to dark man I'll tell you what they have
a horrible time act and spread the
lyrics and when they're kids
holy [ __ ] train that crazy nuts oh well
that was ten years ago when they shot
this play long of that that's nuts
oh yeah that's a lot of fun by the way
go back that's a lot of fun to be in
that make that'll be five hour no one
knows whose father still works
oh and you're walking around and you're
wearing a green screen [ __ ] they used
stunt guys for that oh but also like no
one like you there's me yet to be
anybody there could be anybody correct
you're Negative Nancy today huh yeah
yeah going on on G ot nothing's going on
you hate on acting like a don't know I
don't like if you talk to them they love
it dude uh I've talked to lots of them I
have to who knows if they love it maybe
look they're on them Dragonite I
wouldn't assume everyone's miserable
oh that's your I'm just saying that it's
not it's the the the stuff you do in
between acting can be rather tedious
that's all times they look miserable
there I bet they're sick of counting
their money whatever makin how much are
they making a lot look that up chin I
know how much one guys I don't want say
anything I mean it's stupid money the
main actors the the the the core cast
yeah they probably all did got together
and did a favorite nations thing five
hundred grand an episode 2017 no they're
not making five thousand episode chin
that's what says first 2017
more than that you're saying yeah
how much more just depends on on the
main ones like I think Peter Dinklage is
the highest-paid yeah you got it you're
only making six episodes 1 million for
these guys Peter Nick collage Lena
Headley how do you go in there Clark
them they'll get a million walk with
three million dollars at the episode per
episode it's less than I thought well
after taxes in Commission you're making
you still walking with three corn too
chichi three actress in his net worth 13
yeah sixth time you sit less than I
thought yeah a lot of that money goes
into production you know this is such a
expensive you know it's such an
expensive show to make yeah that's the
most offensive of all time yeah and how
about they wanted to do more seasons of
it mm-hm they do they wanted them yeah
they're like a nose well it's such a
good show how do you think if they're if
you're there AJ you bike to a million an
episode we're still you're still making
so at the end of it if they if they
saved their money I wonder how much how
long have they been making that kind of
money probably the past
I would imagine past five years I don't
know yeah kiss the shows been a hit for
a while you know it's tough now these
days though to get paid like you don't
get paid like the friends get paid or
like do you know how much the big bang
three people make I've taught him so
much you looked up that Konami looked up
that a million dollars an episode
they make twenty so make me more than
that know that well here's how here's
how it goes they made twenty four
million dollars for the season but also
remember it's in syndication so you can
add on another three million dollars
that four million I don't know where
you're finding this [ __ ] chin so your
talk about everything is just a
flat-rate million well no milli million
is what they make about on Big Bang no
they're no they're making so much more
than that so listen so alright so I've
gone over the big beans is a top spot
thanks to 27 million earn yeah I can
tell you how much I'm making I know how
much they're making that but plus you
add tack on another three formally knows
is you occasion yeah so you're making
you're walking with 27 million dollars a
[ __ ] see there y'all come on they
each made 26 Mel Jesus Christ I mean
come on he's a great [ __ ] guy by the
way come on
but who made ya keep saying his name who
made friends it was friends the
highest-paid of all time no I think
these guys big bunch I'm gonna make sure
wasn't it Charlie Sheen for a show oh he
got he had a hero he said yeah Charlie
show made he was I pay guy on TV for a
while God he's killed it and the Ray
just went crazy
yeah yeah and then they replaced him
with uh Ashton Kutcher yeah then Astros
give me get paid bank then everyone was
crying these guys makes nice paid TV
actors
2018 Oh mark big bangs on the list like
at the top of the list I don't he'll
still make him Bank he's never stopped
work but bring up how much Charlie Sheen
was making chin
I wonder how much longer they're just
people like this I think it all depends
on how many people are watching and what
what kills with the new digital how do
you because that's where everyone's
gonna watch it yeah whether you know
this not most of the actors that we know
are not making a lot of money and
especially because you don't shoot the
same number of episodes anymore
when you're shooting 24 episodes of
making that you're making real money but
this is the very rarely do machine on
basically 2 million apps the most people
doing these Amazon shows HBO shows
they're not gonna make you money no not
me what's same with like the but the
Disney like you think like Kristen Bell
like the frozen Disney is like nah man I
think they they lock it up before that
the contracts all like the the kids who
do uh Lord of the Rings you know that
you think they'd be making mm-hmm no
like no it's gonna be a hit with you in
it or not I'm story sells a friend of
mine a friend of mine turned it down to
be one of the hobbits and I remember
when it all happened and he was like I
said no and it was a three it was a
three you know what we have Hellboy on
track every I don't believe in it yeah I
had another guy my buddy and he and I
saw what the numbers were and I was like
mmm not really worth it
cuz they do they lock you into these
these contracts but you can always kind
of if it's a hit you can always be like
oh she ate even if you're in a contract
you can be like well well shred it's
wrecked they got they made their money
in Shrek 2 3 yeah that's when they get
me yeah and it's like cars cars they
make Bank and Ice Age
that's right Ray Romano and Ice Age all
the guys all yeah I figure though the
landscapes gonna change his digital so
big now and it's it already has changed
the production's not as creation there's
just so many different shows that
there's its niche audiences it's not
it's very rare that Game of Thrones this
is a phenomenon that so many people are
watching it and waiting for it because
that's not how the model works anymore
but this might go back to the old model
like I like this it asked me I love it I
love the anticipation like I'm shy I
felt like it was Super Bowl Sunday I
like could not wear I can't run I was
that excited you have to have a show
this good though it's really hard to
pull that off good luck trying to make a
show that good the money involved that's
the craziest part I mean I was diagnosed
smart those
with Game of Thrones mmm like as far as
like weaving all those different
characters and stories together it's
like how the [ __ ] do you keep that in
your head oh my god I guess they've said
they've known for the past three seasons
that that when a Ariane start was gonna
be the one who kills the night king like
we've known it sir
your your spoiler alert here dude a
billion people watched it it came out
last night and the UK is seen it by now
all right there's no spoiler everybody
see it if you haven't I don't know what
to tell you
did you see it yeah I saw it CAD you see
it yeah Jin doesn't watched you don't
watch it but I would have seen it if you
were seen an episode of Game of Thrones
huh
Why What if you have any what like we
can't you can't dictate the our show and
what we want to talk about based off if
you didn't have time to watch it or not
do you imagine that sport you know watch
some dude come on man I had to fight DVR
it's like well no what happened though
that's true
I mean this hair's on Tuesday sir if
it's the day of then yeah there'd be a
spoiler or like movie I think movies a
little bit you gotta wait a little
longer but still you get I think I think
a week do they think you know how many
people did they think watched I think up
with illegally streaming and all around
the world in other countries up billing
P no that's too many that's what I got
is that listen to me I don't think a 7th
or an eighth of the world's population
watched it no sir most watched episode
of all time I would say I would say 200
million at the most last one did over
200 million yeah that's still a lot
Elliot's a lot
I guess the Avengers made 1.2 billion
dollars billion dollars that's crazy
now that would be a spoiler if I like
that and I read I already know what
happens cuz people you know just it's
out there I didn't see it no I'm not
gonna see it either I'm sure I'll get
into in a bad year from now how was a
Phoenix thanks cool yeah hot that's [ __ ]
no chill no I'm not like that hot it
just hit a hundred oh oh it's a hundred
one hundred well that's very hot not too
bad too hot isn't it a too bad at night
I feel like I was tired man like a
dehydrated no no I just I think I was
thinking sleep and I drank red bull's
eyes up all my okay I can hate really
you told me about that yeah I was up
what do you do you drink just a bunch of
Red Bulls yeah yeah I could not sleep I
drank a tan in Denver I drank
somebody said try this al morrow which
is a a botanical liqueur whatever the
[ __ ] is in those roots I'm telling you
dude I was up at a bar yeah I was up all
night I was like I was literally like
dude oh dude let me see leave me a wet
dog Ronald yeah
it's actually kind of nice you'd
probably go yeah yeah that's right I
haven't had that snow there's got to be
some caffeine in that [ __ ] I don't know
what is in there cuz it's like Abbott
and ring with Cody no I drank with my
buddy ray he was drinking it dude Cody
come show yeah yeah first night it's
great to hang with Cody sugar took I
went to it I went to Easton's gym took a
class with Vinny Lopes there's Cody's
train out of Easton's or no he trains
out of well they they they were training
at if they were doing jiu-jitsu it they
were actually doing like light drill
sparring at Easton's yeah so so it was
they still all go to the gyms Neil Magny
that this guy boy on yeah it was Curtis
blaze was there he was rolling with the
Samoan dude I was pretty cool Curtis
plays real cool guy you know him I've
never met him very long though a good
guy really cool guys Cody's doing well I
see yep
and not sure how Neil Magli gets magnet
sound the 170 cuz I was seven eight
standing next to him when I was like I'm
so much shorter and small you
he's a thin one seven he's ten though
he's got skinny legs and stuff she's all
good guys she's all Darren tell you [ __ ]
your pants if I saw what do until huge
huge it's ridiculous yeah yeah it's fini
fini I think he's a fight coming up he
does in May May 14th he's flying under
the radar yeah well he took some time
off and and they're there and Cody's
teacher-training over him and who was
one his last two fights Hudson sure
that's who they gave Neil Magny that's
cool he also he's gone international and
fighting his [ __ ] he just doesn't care
yeah seems like a very easygoing guy did
you train with him yeah yeah Neil was
with us read off the Ultimate Fighter
he's a medic in the million military oh
yeah great guy I'm gonna give him the
nickname the Gazelle I don't know if
they still climbing oh really
cuz cardio you're gonna write he's a
real thin doesn't get doesn't get tired
never get started
beat Kelvin Gastelum people forget pity
yeah did lost his last fight you'd like
to ruff and then he beat Kelvin and a
decision he beat Johnny Hendrix Hector
Lombard Kelvin Gastelum yeah yeah so is
only like Achilles heels
jujitsu he Carlos Condit damn yeah he's
a great career man great could then when
he fights the jusu guys it's struggle
City why is that just just enough I mean
there's a super high level they get to
the ground I don't know but you know
it's Demian Maia
it's [ __ ] yeah dos Anjos and then his
the one guide inverted triangle
Sergio Morales or whatever great dude
though yeah all those guys at altitude
are super friendly Cody's a friendly
dude great guy yeah well I always forget
that kids name Cory eyes sans and Hagen
looked really good against Linacre
that's Christian Allen's uh project yeah
Cory's a good dude
he's a basketball player yeah I guess
he's been training at high altitude
since he was 16 kid man oh and you know
I saw your boy I took a picture with
those guys
Oh Jeff Susskind yeah good guy really
close friend of mine yeah yeah good guy
right Jeff took me under his wing yeah
yeah yep so super stunt I think he's
getting married soon you say that I
don't know it looks great my nose right
means you're a shredded yes super health
nut good looks like he's good at Jiu
Jitsu to a black belt good
no he's amazing yeah yeah do you roll
them I didn't roll them yeah I did not I
don't roll my only box
oh my box with he's amazed and there's
the lead singer of tool a really cool
guy what the [ __ ] is this no Trent
Reznor Maynard oh yeah what strainers a
really cool guy Maynard Keenan right
yeah I'm a turkey need funny cool guy
purple ball jujitsu yes that's his ass
Manzo's super smart guy he looked like
he was good he looked thick and this mom
by the way he's not he's a tiny man mom
Nick though thick monsters in the real
monsters in that gym though you got some
[ __ ] dudes where you're just like I
mean the class they probably had 30
people rolling you know my girl Jesus
and you like oh that guy's an Olympic
judo guy that guy's a tear roll I rolled
in forever that wouldn't let him rolled
with me probably
I just hogs yeah I think I'm too I think
I'm too old my own [ __ ] over here you
know I get hurt yeah I feel like this
too by the way there's just us probably
easier handsome devil for sure Yeah
right
Jeff's oskins the guy who took me in his
wing when I first start fretting UFC
he's a black belt I can afford like
privates and he took me it would douche
do privates with me really yeah super
stud the nicest guy Wow then he was also
when I think yeah that's coming off one
of my losses and he hired these mental
coaches for me from they work with Navy
SEALs I still used a lot of their
techniques today hmm
smart guy there's Benny Lopez right
there's Martin
this is Susskind Paige yeah and Jeff was
such a monster he would bring in
Brazilians we're like top black boat
guys and have them teach courses and
just like the nicest guy in me huh yes
Wade gets smart too stupid smart he owns
a bunch of
businesses yeah restaurant it's a hell
of an entrepreneur right yeah so you're
very good with money kind of a
high-functioning dude I guess in every
way
that's a I'm pretty sure he's getting
married I probably should go the wedding
cuz I'm such an [ __ ] I but I won't
you were made his wifey there and it
made me laugh so hard I'm there with
Cody and that where I'm talking to you
know Brendan's got all his friends there
and he goes he said man I'm I don't I
don't I really haven't talked to anybody
there in a while cuz I'm so much better
than they are now I told I say that's a
[ __ ] Cody cuz like [ __ ] you yeah
Cody's the one place I'd Mecca I mean
after I miss us a few people I miss I
miss girls that died me so so who's got
attractive girls um but um yeah I miss
uh skin I'm it often my family's there
but outside that price sauce and Cody
it's about it in Lauren land oh yeah
holiday matter came to the show great
coat me Cody was super look he's the
best she's mean killer
Cody and I who Cody is a guy who you can
have such deep conversations with Cody
is a very smart almost too smart to be a
fighter and you should if I say this
probably replace his biggest promise
code is such a cerebral well-read
thinker yeah that are hiding that does I
help right phenomenal artists all the
high altitude drawings you see is all
Cody and wrong he's a [ __ ] monster
yeah he's a very smart kid yeah a
hundred percent you can talk to God we
got some funny [ __ ] times and easily
Kody's funny too very funny no one's
made me laugh farther than Cody and
fighting oh my god he's I remember when
me and him were fighting uh it was like
our first two big fights we fight in
Washington DC I got set up with this guy
named Johnny Curtis he was like they
told me he had high school wrestling
turns out he was on the national team
all-american he was older than what
they're trying to set me up and then
Cody was fighting like one of his
training partners this guy looked like a
like it using a biker gang shaved head
where I can't what what how does Jiu
Jitsu is this stuff you just don't want
to see or pulling into the hotel and we
see his opponent in the yard in the
hotel trying to armbar like it like
their training just in grass in the yard
but it was like so amateur like
and I go and then I go oh dude there's
your opponent and could he go slow down
so let's see what he's doing and we all
start dying laughs when you get to Elko
he's like I bet he's just [ __ ] around
I bet he's really good I'm like no no
he's deaf in on me I'm like no he's
definitely not hey guys so awful dude
and everyone's like you better not lose
tomorrow you could just so like put the
pressure on I'm like you better not lose
the guy doing jujitsu in the grass
practicing armbars old school but he
smoked him could he knock them out in
like 30 seconds
yeah and I knocked my gut like 50
seconds is the best we've had some good
time I'm really cody gets balls deep
into Halloween like goes all out he goes
deep into that show yo look at him look
at him anything buying a sword with that
[ __ ] loves it look at he's dressed
exactly like the guy would so for
Halloween Cody goes super into it so he
was up Frank summers girlfriend at the
time was like Miss Frankenstein she was
in green [ __ ] you know I my brother's a
penguin and I was uh Richard Simmons and
Richard Simmons there's pictures of that
and code Ian's girl they weren't meant
to be but they were they're both drunk
and fighting
so if Frankenstein he looks like
Franklin covered in baby his girl
covering green fighting she was I'm no
the room could I don't give a [ __ ] and
then she gets in the bed with all the
green dye you know I didn't have much
money at the time could he open circus
what me my brother's hammered around the
couch just like doze enough here Cody go
what the [ __ ] my sheets
you've ruined my [ __ ] sheets and then
it World War three starts off my right
and then fired ends with Cody go you
know what
you know what [ __ ] it you didn't die
alone like your mom with seven [ __ ]
cat so [ __ ] funny Jesus Christ
yay Cody's the best man had a girl break
up with me and say say that she goes she
broke up with me and I was like you know
I'm such an [ __ ] I go you break that
with me you are I was like huh
but I'm fun she goes I know I'm probably
gonna die alone with a bunch of cats and
you can see how I was like hot it's
hilarious I'm such an [ __ ] though I
was so shocked I was like me you can't
break up with me I'm awesome yeah see
you later
let's go beyond Holloway
him in the wifey zombies the last one
again when I went to my brother's
wedding my time out dress up I was the
best man at Cody's wedding we're you yep
I told the story how Kody and his wife
met I was there when they met you were I
was there when they met what happened is
my first fight Kody's second fight and
we went out at we both won by knockout
then we went outside do I get hot dogs
and these two girls came up the two
Asian girls came up and I said something
you know cuz I'm / I like the color
psych I can get used to this you know
like something like that and it was
Cody's wife yeah really it's Cody's wife
that's when they met that's the first
time that's amazed and then they like
hung out and Cody was a cot she's so hot
blowin like yep for sure we're just
getting started so don't already get
wifed up yeah okay you know she then I
they met like two years later and then
BOOM oh really got married yeah yeah you
bet there's a [ __ ] women like him y'all
kill he walks a straight line but he's
like yeah he does yeah but but women dig
him well too straight for my liking
yeah he's hilarious yeah hilarious yeah
man it's awesome yeah
Kath how was your weekend what else is
going on with you Brendan not much dude
but what else is what else is happening
your life but you gotta works just life
dude you know man just live in life
alone
yeah quarter mile at a time what do you
mean back quarter mile one quarter mile
time bro like Vin Diesel like Vin Diesel
I don't know what that means either he
lose his life one quarter mile time
right okay so in other words you drag
race I don't drag race it I don't like I
like to race though you like to race
what why am I gonna what do you like
Ferrari 458 or 488 which one do you
provide didn't say anything about
Ferrari I thought you did
I didn't say a damn thing about for is I
forsaking I thought you were like are
you gonna buy a Ferrari cuz I'm I I
didn't I don't know why jeez do you like
put me on the spot wait a minute I'm
just browsing um you don't bro
bro when you brow I live my life 1/4
mile at a time when you I know what
happens now you give Rogan a call and
you say can I do this and he goes do it
and you like but it's super expensive
and he goes shut up don't be a [ __ ]
correct that's he said to me correct and
I didn't listen to him but you're gonna
listen to him are you getting a Ferrari
maybe dude either 48 or 458 what's the
difference well dude I'm so glad yes
once a v8 naturally aspirated and then
ones events to enter Bo I think the
older ones right the oh well better gas
mileage however right they're both the
same as far as speed goes right so you
want to go better gas mileage mm I like
naturally aspirated myself why turbos
and stuff like that
one a 616 horsepower one has five six he
get to the same speed the 488 the new
one the 48 replaced the 450 I was a 48
the v6 with the twin with the 458 the v8
the 488 s-- the new one okay so they
looked almost identical the exhaust is a
little different the engine is
completely different
yeah there it is FRA 458 verse 488 when
you get a new one bro I don't buy new I
buy used always why is that it doesn't
mean as soon as you drive off the lot
you're down like 60 okay 60 K always
also you can't go into fryer it now buy
a 48 GT but you can't no I think it's
mine a 2 3 you're waiting last what why
but K so it goes bro demand then a lot
then sometimes like if you want like the
fours or something like that you can't
like let's say you're a billionaire you
can't go in there violet you have to be
on the list
you can't pile yeah like you and there's
certain portions you just can't walk in
and buy you have to be like really yeah
so so are they made as far as still made
in the same factory or is it owned by
some nope same factory so it's not owned
by Ford or something I forget who owns
um but there's the 48 look at that
[ __ ] thing that's a hell of a car I
have to admit I'm not a car guy but that
looks like a piece of jewelry looks like
a piece of art I don't think you can get
like red but I feel like white or black
might be the way yeah red it's like I
calm down I agree I agree
understand it but let me ask you this
well it seems very low to the ground
don't you [ __ ] it up all the time don't
you have a look at my gt3 RS is super
well what I like about you is you drive
your you get you'll buy a high
performance credit guys would keep it in
and it becomes your primary car yeah I
don't look at am i I like I love to
drive them I like a lot of cars I just I
don't know man
I told Rogan like a we're at The Comedy
Store the other night and he pulled up
in his new Land Cruiser which is amazing
it's a zombie apocalypse mobile that he
had custom-made it's ridiculous of it so
I was like dude I'm looking at a 450 and
a 488 I know when you think it's gonna
stop you it won't it never well you're
always gonna be like this who's on the
same way again I thought when I get the
RS I'd be fine no you never never gonna
be happy you love cars love them
absolutely love that's why people have a
ton of them but um it's it's a pretty
well gonna into cars though people I do
what are you doing I'm sure I like that
Land Cruiser he has those are sick but
like Mikey Garcia on food truck Diaries
and he act like he races cars he does
yeah like straight-up races Wow
yeah that's it chin the white and black
bro that's what I'm digging right now
with red interior it's a hell of a car
dude yeah it's come out of that car at
all
you shouldn't be man why be mad at that
car just feel like Reds woman sighing
calm down dude I think great guy to
black is a way to go I'm out in the car
that's a hell of a car I feel like it's
so low you're gonna hit things all that
like my Porsche is lower really yes but
Porsche and Frey have buttons but when
you go up to curbs it lifts it
what's faster that Carla Porsche whoa
well you just made a race car noise on
track why's that my Porsche destroys
that thing really my Jay Saab will talk
[ __ ] all day about four hours there you
go the Porsche gt3 RS the gt2 RS destroy
a thing on the track or how about I was
like eh I'm I'm clean about pulling the
trigger on this 458
said to be a video of a McLaren just
dusting and like all right well well I'm
not racing like I'm not buying it
because of the quarter-mile time you go
but you are like no I'm not I'm
literally Jason so you're about this far
into cars in your
right now way more way more I'll tell
everything about my car this car really
yeah he's going to it he's details for
this nautical my dad tries to call him
out well my dad says he has some option
on his car
but Jay knows cars so well he just
destroys it I don't know why that brings
me joy I might get is s think releasing
your pitbull yeah mailman yeah I don't
know why why do we like that but but
Jason Porsche guy Porsche Porsche make
learner but Porsche like knows them
better than clarin loves mcloon those
are just as expensive I mean [ __ ] karate
I mean the 488 the McLaren 5/7
interesting about your pores that you'll
sell your portion our trade it in and
you'll get you'll get a lot of money for
it right I mean D thing yeah I'm not
gonna be you know what I'm saying yeah
you're not gonna lose money you're
almost in a way you're driving it for a
lot cheaper than people think cuz you
see your money back
okay you know I mean now now let me get
immediate make clearance don't look as
good now let me ask you this now
performance wise that thing was [ __ ] on
like I told you how much I spent on
horses for my lovely my lovely wife and
my daughter and I think you did I pulled
you a goodbye Ferrari I told you that
whatever you said pick one pick a car
pick any car you want picking out if you
get the superfast one but there's one
for I call this price superfast
how much horses I mean we're talking me
an estimate 3500 sure I don't know five
I don't know how good's a restful
everything I don't know how much either
way thirty-five you do it there's the
soup out someone I thought it looked
like a Corvette how do you mean a
Corvette that's a fish oh yeah you mean
a Corvette looks like that sir the fat I
don't like that car that's two I don't
like that small to light in the ass that
thing's bigger than I need an ass on my
car to light in the ass there is no ass
I need an ass on my car bub I can't have
that to light in the ass that's a short
summary law he lost his ass NASA tall
mm-hmm
I mean come on I'd cut off one of my
toes for like really oh yeah super fast
a boss who profess how fast is it it's
super fast it says in the title dude
yeah dad tests us do you like the you
like the the 488 and the 450 been in
that honey
much better much better what about you
chin I don't like sports cars really
well I like my keys ready take these
Brandon Brandon take it easy
hold on Brandon Brandon take it easy let
me out let me handle this
hold on sit down let me handle this
Letty he's probably just [ __ ] with
you relax
hold on hold on chin yeah
chin yes what are you dry right now
2015 Toyota Prius good now June okay
Brad hey penny it's white chin I'm gonna
head chin I'm gonna give you 200 go you
have any car you want what is it 200
grand um a Bentley now you brought a
truck I mean I like a fancy Raptor like
that that you wanted Malloy in a truck
but you don't you want that post Malone
Raptor the six-wheeler luxury cars what
Lex is behind it for sports question let
me let me just run sports cars cars
don't watch sports don't watch TV don't
watch Game of Thrones sings he sings do
sing you did post up videos the new
video singing but I once sent me a thing
with like dude [ __ ] and [ __ ] sing
too bad he's a murderer okay where did
you post it I just did my story
it's already gone ah [ __ ] on your phone
now but dude you're full of [ __ ] where's
it at bro I think it's gonorrhea you can
get okay
I'm not proud of that one by the way
what are you singing
a Randy Travis song it was good it was
good thank you
dude have you ever realized how many
followers cat has know my brother's
talking [ __ ] to his friend his friend
was like this weird buster we bring on
the road he said something about being
tired Jase like scuse me he goes because
joking is it we're altering news because
me you're friends with a celebrity and I
was like hey man let's larrya's know me
I've 10,000 followers you have 10,000
videos
yeah man I just hit 10k I went holy [ __ ]
I went home he just can't have that I
was like 30 K damn yeah man I see them
feet girl the amount of people asking
for photos of my
is almost offensive hey send it to me I
have adorable feet send it people have
asked for my dad's feet what the right
make money make money bro yes are your
feet yeah [ __ ] J shop and 10k do you
see the poster I put pic that you see
the picture I posted of J that's great
it's fantastic because he's top listen
to see you like I was gonna comment
you're gonna love this he goes hey I'm
somewhere in my tank taught me as I
don't have a / should I go I have that
my damn sure you can wear over you guys
yeah I feel like an [ __ ] in this I go
yeah we're right up the club just wear
that out and I'll give it to you in the
green room use okay cool
when they ready oh hey real quick guys
no no and they take pictures hillarious
he looks ridiculous these giants here
he's my dick kid man it's very strong
yeah
very strong I know he said to me he goes
we're talking about lifting I tells you
and he goes like this everything he said
he got cuff you know he gets like his he
gets kind of serious I'm talking about
lifting and stuff and he goes we're
eating kind of middle of the day
anything goes I'll lift 500 pounds I'll
deadlift 500 pounds right now if you put
it on the ground anymore and up here
I'll pick it up right now
he's very white he's I don't know do you
you get you have much brownish skin in
them actually yeah oh yeah so is my son
though yeah I was late for my show time
show below the belt today cuz I had
parent-teacher conference Venus and what
they said about Tiger nice kid in the
class funniest kid in the class goofy
but too friendly has too many friends
and with his toys this is the bet the
bad comments that with his toys if
someone comes up like oh let me have
this he doesn't fight for his toys like
yeah you can have it this he's tuna I
was the same way
saves tuna it was the exact same way oh
so he's really generous and not attached
to material [ __ ] yeah they said they
said maybe at home like you know what
big when you're when he's playing with
toys like take it like you sure you
don't want this I'm like I don't know
that way at all I gave my my mother
would get so mad cuz I gave all my [ __ ]
away yeah they're like he doesn't like
he'll be playing with the toy kids come
up and take and he just moves on yeah
but I was the same way my mother I gave
all my stuff away all the time that's
not a bad thing worked out for me so
he's really generous who gives a [ __ ]
about stuff yeah I don't know I don't
care about so I was the only negative
this is negative if it's not a negative
I understand that but you don't wanna be
pushed you don't wanna be a pushover
it's not gonna be a pushover he's
already muscular it's always nice it's
gonna be a mom a just super friends she
not straps they say is the most friends
in the class though and he's gonna be as
good they said he only had a group of
four band I was expanded to understand
he's gonna be an athlete or not he's
built what'd you do this weekend cat um
well I went back home to San Jose to see
my family you're back home this week
okay enough yeah for a little bit went
and saw my younger brother my sister
came back into town hey hey good still
waiting for the slide my dance yeah what
is she in school mm-hmm you didn't post
any pictures at home no not yet cam was
30,000 followers and you think says hi
please be kind people's game them cat
huh people be mean I know and then
there's like couple of [ __ ] now I
think it's to a point where it's funnier
now that I'm vegan just blog yeah but it
like only black people who send me dick
pics
oh really yeah but now I feel like that
keeps on giving
I'm a bit more desensitized to it so I
stop blocking used to depict yeah yeah I
mean will they just send you a dick I
know how yeah yeah like I get a lot of
dick pics pics too like beer cans and
beer bars for scale so it's like dick
and then there's like a Bud Light right
exit asshat first of all send them to me
and also also so I can marvel at it yeah
it's gonna be like we also sent it to us
so we can have a great time here great
nothing like you do you get take pics -
oh yeah I'm gay man titty ass
leave it on its feet actually oh you
don't and then not take though yeah it's
very strange but when I realized that
they usually you can you know I can win
the internet like dinner Internet's
undefeated is one P I know we joke
around but like be obligate the episode
three of Game of Thrones was a little
dark hard to follow us on the fight
scenes but in general was pretty [ __ ]
phenomenal but when I see the amount of
hate yeah every time like to know Wow or
like when people hate on like Kevin
Durant after performance he gave them
like oh wow
like there's no you have any oh that's
good and I don't know one's gonna go
undefeated in on the internet it's just
it's just that it breeds negativity
that's just first yes we shall ignore it
most people are cool though most people
don't most people are dope yeah yeah
yeah if you want to find negativity can
find it but in general most people it
dope but yeah came back on Sunday and I
watched endgame and then I came home and
watched Game of Thrones
oh you saw in game yes did you love it
yes I cried you cried yes that could
well not necessarily it was very good
but also it's been 10 11 years I watched
all the movies so it's just
who's the end game yeah it was like the
last hurrah see but that's how I was
with Game of Thrones like I've been so
balls deep inner like that's what I do
on Sundays order my pizza like it's like
a routine hit me like damn it's all over
man series actually what I heard it's
gonna they're gonna come out with
another series within that world equal
yeah you will you never we say now to do
start progress I'm going once this is
over I'm going it you're gonna be like
[ __ ] I'll be giving you guys update my
people super dude don't spoil it man
spawns came out you're 90 that's how
this game what sounds like [ __ ] man my
reasoning of surprise now that you've
seen all these other shows that's a
that's why I was worried about this is
same production quality holds up I still
think it still holds up you know what
people I do you guys see this movie and
then it's just you used to want things
real mafia though like it's like it's
like gritty it's like what it would I
like that
but it sound like like my son right like
he's used to [ __ ] you know Ice Age
and Pixar movies if you show him a
cartoon that's not highly produced he's
like get this [ __ ] out of my face ya
hurts what are you doing dad already
doing this looks like stick figures how
many of these guys are working
everything takes a long time
and I mean you know like a snack yeah
that's not hating on this guy not hating
quite a good thing that's not just
saying is that fault it's just a hard
it's just a hard acting's hard it's
writing songs or anything we're doing
hard so I'm saying it's not a hard
business it's a thought leadership what
you're doing I had a great run two somos
guys I'm sure doing great some don't
care yeah let's go to convinced you here
we go
so there is a website called herp alert
and balloon yes people can actually send
in photos of what they think may be
herpes and there is a doctor who runs
the site who will then tell you like oh
this probably is herpes or a doctor not
college kid but yeah maybe but they've
noticed that there was a huge spike on
their website within the two weeks
Coachella was happening usually they get
about 20 photos per day while Coachella
was happening they got 250 photos each
and every day she's cream which came out
to eleven hundred and five different
cases that they diagnosed yeah the kids
are [ __ ] man get the [ __ ] you like oh
why else would you go to the desert
listen to music yeah exactly
I like how everyone's hey you know I
actually looks really fun you want to
have sex inside a van tied up inside a
tent I mean in the desert yeah in a tent
well you hear people all around you what
Saul what's the other thing they do up
north in the desert Burning Man
yes you catch it hate that Burning Man
hey catch a lot of things well just
herpes don't be so don't you take a pill
yeah take a pill for the rest of your
life true that's probably the best is he
well know chlamydia spread the best oh
yeah take a shower hold it forever
ya know they've had it yeah but people
have had I mean apparently you've been
exposed to herpes and whether or not you
get it or not depends on your genetics
but some people you know the math
offensive either sexually your mouth you
have a better chance of not getting it
on your genitals because you have an
inherent immunity to it either way it's
not good
my cousin you wanna hang out with a girl
with Claire with chlamydia and they used
to call her Claire midea and when she
walks in the room they used to just give
her a round of applause so she had a lot
mean you just take did she take a pill
or something or a shot yeah poor girl
yeah poor girl but then again like she
liked that drip you like though all the
homies you know it's not like the homies
had it to a lot of guy a lot of people
have it they don't know it good
chlamydia and gonorrhea can be
asymptomatic mm-hmm so and a lot of wait
a minutes a problem cuz you can go yeah
a lot of men don't know that they have
it yeah well I told you I talked to my
friend Mike you've never used a condom
Annamma it's just he was short with just
five or six I was like dude that girl is
like crazy now oh my god I was like any
guy could jeez economy was 90 that
should I never want to kind of my own
I know but dude she's a she's [ __ ] on
film a lot now listen it's fine but you
just need to he goes uh you know he has
I'll say later he goes I I never had
that I he goes I mean my I've had two my
dick is tripped before but nothing you
know I know that's called chlamydia or
carrying a [ __ ] dummy
yeah can you do dude
take a pill take four pills at the same
time what else yet but speaking of
spoilers this man in Hong Kong watched
the Avengers end game stayed outside of
the theater and started saying spoilers
out loud as people were coming and going
people were so angry that he got beat
while other people were cheering on it
had to be hospital that's probably best
that's what you get that's kind of what
you guess what she gets kind of that's
what you get is this them being his ass
that's them trying to get right and help
they're tending no he should be fun
I just don't something wrong I do but
you might be that you just need so much
attention you got to do this well
there's something wrong with him how
about but the LeSean McCoy were the [ __ ]
isn't the running back at the pills the
same thing tweeted out spoilers why did
you do with millions of dollars what are
you doing why did he tweet out spoilers
people already hate you would like what
do you do away why would you do that I
don't get it man I don't get it either
that is weird
- yet Jen took you long enough
so this 27 year old mother who is also a
rapper um got arrested because one
morning she ordered a lift and she
dropped off her child in the lift told
the driver hey can you take my son to
his school and the driver said I can but
you need to be in the car as well he
needs a guardian she said okay walk back
in her house didn't it come back out so
the driver took the child but took the
chance at the police department I said
that she abandoned her child so now
she's in jail come on now I would never
ever ever [ __ ] do this and definitely
a suspect how old's the kid five like
young that's not cool some parents have
to work and they have no choice she's
rapper no but she may have another job
she's also I don't I don't know III yeah
I don't know maybe she was like you are
tracking the child in a car I mean
people are getting murdered by uber
drivers fake uber drivers by here yeah I
mean I would never do it but I have no
idea yeah maybe she was like here take
this uber get but he's five so he has to
jump out the car figure thing I said mom
move back my mom I have a problem with
this public shaming is my problem social
media like thank you just have her face
there and I don't know all the details
but now we're all like look at her you
know but also would like the uber driver
did you have to go the cops but it's
gone because if but you know again you
might have got a weird vibe in like this
thing oh yeah like you should be a good
guy yeah you got a five-year-old you
have to do such shitty you're not gonna
drop the kid off at school you can't do
that you'd be in trouble then so yeah in
today's world she goes back in the house
what are you supposed to do you imagine
the kid and dropped off at five years
old and be like I guess I'll walk this
way feel a terrible for men how old do
you have to be to take it uber by
yourself
is there like a I know I don't know but
I know you feel like a lot teens take
uber teens do like so like driver
license like if you talk to kids like in
high school like why the [ __ ] would I
give my driver license like no one's
passing their driving test they don't
care
like I'll just uber why would I get a
car cuz you don't because when I was a
kid there's no ober I would say my
eleven your all
daughter cuz she's really I would it
well I would not do a short distance
from my house to my to school because
she knows the way and she knows people
how old is she she's 11 how about a
do-over like I wouldn't know her like my
my girl's mom she lives far away I was
getting into uber I don't even do that
well you know you never know right you
don't know who this guy oh there's a new
thing where people get murdered in
Shepparton and I'm not worried about
that I'm worried about an uber guy I
don't know what correct no it's just I
just don't know but because the ubers
associated with you assume well you you
they don't do any background check how
they do actually they do they do very
extensive background that's not true I
promise is you know why I know that
because our boy Stevie can of a felony
yeah different yeah so that would be
doing extensive background checks I can
check felony on my fault
yeah but as far as anything like you
know felony yes but their thing you
don't know what they know you don't know
yeah you're right you're right you don't
you just assume it because he's an uber
driver that you thought good yeah that's
a you can track your kid you can track
the time and your kid yeah on your phone
with uber so if my kids going two miles
away I can track that and if I'm gonna
bind I would send my 11 year old I
wouldn't send my seven-year-old my 11
year old smart enough to I guess she she
could call me I I would never do it
anyway I've never do it I don't put that
much trust into Buber drivers to with my
child at Dineen age so he's taking fend
for himself
yeah law of averages what are the
chances all that pros cons
yeah cons five is too young cons
but that hang on you for thing probe I'd
have to get my car drop my kid off at
work Khan your kid gets raped by an uber
driver huge cons people pros cons that's
what I live in that's not every parent
yeah that's what let's oh my god I'll
figure it out yeah what else yet
so a couple of days ago blac chyna
released a acceptance letter that says
that she was accepted into Harvard
Business School and a lot of people who
attend Harvard currently and have
attended Harvard in the past got really
angry about this saying that because of
the stigma surrounding Bach China that
their degrees now may be seen as I guess
in a way tainted because because now
she's receiving a business degree from
Harvard
some people were so upset that they
reached out to admissions at Harvard and
Harvard did some investigating and they
said that one whatever she posted out
this acceptance letter is fake and they
don't have anybody under her legal name
accepted into the school and two they
found out that a PR firm that she hired
actually told her she can enroll in
Harvard Business School's online program
so not actually go onto campus and
they're trying to set up a PR move where
people will enroll into their online
course and then go to Harvard take
photos pretend like oh I attend Harvard
Business School so you can put it on
your resume when you're the Harvard
Business School online like top is it
see me not as I miss Harvard no it's
definitely easier to get into I'm not
quite sure how online school Harvard
Business it yes
[ __ ] I'm at Harvard yeah yeah cuz you
can put it on your resume that's online
from Harvard but I don't think because
you had to grieve I don't think so
either
so Jordan II agree though like I said
like Nicole Arbour digital yeah I'd be
reppin the [ __ ] of a Harvard sweatshirt
though so she wanted to look like she
was taking business yeah and this pure
Mizrahi what they're doing they're
trying to do this with a lot of
influencers so the whole thing is just
enroll in these classes will take most
of the course for you and then you just
have to pass the exam and they'll set a
study sheet for you and black China came
out and said that she actually wanted to
do the course herself and that she
wanted to actually attend Harvard
Business here
so it says uh so they'll take the course
for T for $1000 and you'd feel like a
schmuck if you had a sign up for Harvard
online schools and then had someone take
the class for East and then you got a
fake degree the whole thing is weird
it's very strange
the kids who did the college cheating
scandal should have done this I'm about
to get my degree from Harvard though
Karia so let's start off with the bad
news it's pretty recent right now - once
it loads but pretty much you know John
Singleton director of boys in the head
so he went to a coma he had a stroke
right oh yeah he was in there for 12
days and they took his life support off
last week or 12 days ago
Yeah right director that's [ __ ] dogs
stroke first then in a coma and then
they took him off life support just now
Wow man must had a hard 51 man cuz young
Wow I have to return from Costa Rica
experience some problems with his legs
checked himself into Cedars yeah we
suffered a stroke he was in the hospital
and suffered a stroke and he still died
[ __ ] dude that's horrible
yeah they they I told you that
cardiologist said to me you will lose
friends from the age of 45 and 55 so
scared and then died so so it's called a
Widowmaker there's a compromise
somewhere in your arterial management
it's so weird man you guys are fine
right blood pressure-wise yeah I just
had a whole checkup apparently I'm very
healthy
the other one is another person that got
a stroke and is now in cardiac arrest
that's a Larry King who Larry King's
older though oh there are kings nanny
there it is he'd be farting on air nun
stuff so old he's definitely old
yeah he's 9 years he's something crazy
show it's a show - you know that there
it's like a fake show though right I
don't know he's like a it's a you see
his name is Jay on from Brownsville um
but he's nice he's I'm here I'll talk
sure he's a he's a 85 yeah are younger I
thought so a good run
oh man it suffered a heart attack tank
when you're his age starts suffering
heart attacks it's yeah it's getting
there you know yeah it's a [ __ ]
bummer
yeah what else you got chin oh I bet
heart attacks she's my friend
I've heard my friend who owned Aleutian
hold who owned the comic strip well you
see he was it wasn't he was a partial
IRA mainly there the manager the first
gotta give me my break yeah as a comic
so I always had such a thing and he had
something called scleroderma which is a
terrible disease and he was gonna die
and I went out to dinner with him I took
him out of dinner 2 weeks before he died
and he he had to stop to breathe because
we had walked to the end of the block
and he said to me yeah he's such a
regular I guess he said yeah my doctor
told me to get things in order and so
I'm trying to help my girlfriend and I'm
and he's just talking like that and so
you know in those situations you go you
go no but you know your doctors don't
know there could be a thing and he goes
he goes hey they know yeah it's coming
here I was like he was 53 or something
what else get Jen let's start with this
one Conor McGregor oh I was 1 billion
for his proper whiskey and it out it
actually beat Jameson hey um now let me
ask them
you think he owns 10% right more yeah
buy more yeah I never do well but I
didn't know I was gonna be this good I
thought I'd do that but I thought it
would do exceptionally well that's
amazing so Pete yeah people like oh he
should fight man okay yeah yeah it's
gonna be tough for him why would you
fight he said that it's in his blood
that he had like as a fighter he has to
have that still you think y'all fight
again and I'll see what I don't see what
the upside I probably well yeah because
he's me bored there's so much money's
gonna be bored and the opportunities
gonna be there and then your season
gonna hey will paid this much alright
yeah be fun to go through camp and get
the fans going again specially and get a
win mm-hmm I bet fights again you
I really think see absolutely not if I
was him but that's why I mean that's
what it's him that's got you still be
doing a lot of stuff though right if you
were a billionaire right now or would
you just want to lay back and not do
anything nothing would change I'd have
more car that's it I live in the same
house no I show the wanted you stand up
there's nothing like stayin out do my
podcast I couldn't I like doing this I
don't I don't do any of this for money I
don't need to do stand-up I make enough
money doing this I don't have to do
stand-up I just stand because I love it
I'll have to do other shows i doing
because I want to there you go another
thing that will change to be traveling
it flying I'd have more cars that's it
and I'd have an assistant that you'd
have to talk you to get to me what yeah
what it's like you'd ask me a question
got that right never would get to me you
get in that Ferrari talk to my assistant
[ __ ] man
let me know what she says what else she
up this is kind of messed up assistant
principal I guess you're this at this
school you can't have like any carving
shaved carvings in your head so the
assistant principal gave this kid a few
options either color it with a permanent
marker or call his mom or get suspend or
something like that and then he came
home and his mom saw that they put a
permanent marker up on that little part
hotel miles out to punch a guy in the
dick
he's on leave now that's a that's
ridiculous yeah of course he's only if
you [ __ ] [ __ ] you put [ __ ]
Sharpie on a kid's head cuz he had her
design those dress co-wrote are so
stupid they're so stupid
well they were always enforced as a way
of like discipline and all that stuff
but I don't know couldn't you just put a
hat on him I mean that's the part of
dress yeah but you're doing it in a
good-natured funny way that's just so
ignorant though you can't you can't do
this you serious yeah let me color on
the kid's head with sharpie and send him
back to do it himself though or did the
guy do it that's a good question I think
the principal allowed him to do it yeah
oh let's see here which a design card
did not it hire the dress code the snow
misled she threatened with in-school
suspension less he allowed the shape of
the hair to be filled in with permanent
marker the boy's parents say they were
never notified
they had been they would have taken care
of the issue should have been okay and
you call your mother first okay fill in
the shape in with the market isn't
online with appropriate measures I mean
no matter what you just call the parents
right in this case yeah it can't be
killing on my kid's head and then put a
missus also I don't think I should have
lost their job but just be smart if
you're that you're an adult assistant
principal you can't color a kid's head
yeah yeah you you have to go home if
until you here grows out or something or
just shape go go to the barber have them
shave it or feels like a redhead or
something then I don't know what you
can't do is make the kid color it in
yeah alright moving on this is uh this
is just a silly one but it was just bad
that Joe Biden on his Instagram it says
Biden if you know how he just launched
his campaign for presidency so when you
but you know how you do those Instagram
pictures where you put a bunch of them
together and it makes this one big
picture yeah that's what he didn't so
just ended up with n on Obama that's how
I look eyeing to look for but I mean
people are looking for any excuse it's
just funny I must be racist
I don't think Joe buns come read you
know Joe Budden yeah no monster yeah I
know he's not he's just being to do
funny
no but he was putting Biden and then no
it's just complete on the complete or
whatever it's just to write it was just
funny to see this I think Biden just
[ __ ] you but if this by nor did you say
Joe Budden's calling this Oh Joe Biden
oh I thought you saying Joe Budden's
only attention to it this is how that
story to Joe Budden yeah oh that's a
stupid yeah what are you doing I mean
yeah you definitely picked a better
picture but I don't think he actually is
the one who does any of the absol know
I don't know guy over 50 with seasonal
should be not news this is the weirdest
[ __ ] no this is stupid
yeah his nose you got to be there it's
not winning he's definitely not winning
out I don't but you know he's like it
and running why does he run
that's the Dumber the attention that no
because the Democrats can't get out of
their own way the Democrats are so
divided but they know but like you he
knows deep down he's not gonna win
well they figure he's he's a moderate
alternative to okasha and to Bernie
Sanders so he's a moderate that regular
Americans will vote for problem is he's
75 and nobody gives a [ __ ] and they've
already he's already run like three
times yes like it what I liked it I
might get at it if you know you're not
gonna win yet it's so weird to me and
why do you do it how about the fact that
the economy's doing actually really well
right now in many many sectors including
including in black oh there's the drug
know I'm not giving and I don't usually
give a present that credit it because
honesty the point is that you got Biden
running as sort of Obama light I don't
know that people are gonna get doesn't I
don't see people voting for him it
doesn't make any sense it's got to be a
better alternative a younger more
vibrant alternate it's so wait but I'm
just curious
I guess for the attention or just for
the their party but it's so expensive to
run for president have you ever seen the
numbers if the minimum of some stupid
fundraisers who are the minimum funds
will support him but it's real people
like you know you like gonna win why do
they do it though what like I don't kiss
his egos huge it's your ego right
zübeyde then you go around on this
rah-rah train yeah he's considered a
blowhard by a lot of people yes I know
he's a career politician and it's just
people are like oh god it's so weird to
me it's an ego thing for sure but it's
like it's you you know you're not gonna
win but he you get the attention you can
make the announcement what's over your
party few doughnuts in the green room
but no what he thinks he is he's a
career politician in his bubble
he's got support right so he sees that
and it's like I think I'm gonna do this
I can beat that guy what else yeah chin
you're talking about Joe Budden oh no
this is Bundy not Joe Budden a bud and
the button and be well no one's I just
got mixed up Joe Budden wants bun-bun
beach they're both rappers did he catch
him or he's chaser
he's
so he actually shot him and then he ran
after him the guy took off and then he'd
go to a hospital somewhere he got shot
no the bun be shot the armed robber you
know so he finally and he chased him out
he took off and then eventually the guy
tried to look for help and that's when
he got caught okay we got shot hold in
his chair is a shoulder he broke into
his house yeah well it open it someone
open the door I think is his wife
expecting a package so that's when he
pulled the gun on her and then Bundy ran
down but the interesting thing about
this also is how the guy looks so this
is the guy's face nostril I can see his
brain yeah yeah well he's taking his
picture
dude you're at your picture look at his
ears look at Tommy's yours are is my
well as much like just yeah it's like
I'm not asking to see the bottom of your
chin there sir yeah but I'm also not
looking to look at the to [ __ ] glory
holes in your nose that yeah Jesus
Christ I mean that is Lisa's left eye
straight what if she got through the
last one is just the endgame how it it
broke the box-office panthan really
smooth that been the ultimate no cuz I
know how it ends the biggest opening
ever 1.2 billion who all dried worldwide
it's a lot of [ __ ] movie ticket I got
a son who's seen it cats all but you've
seen all of them right cut mm-hmm doing
your man went to it yep and then you and
your man watch Game of Thrones yeah what
a great night got myself a nice nice
Mulholland Drive pizza watch some Game
of Thrones I have no desire to see end
game though oh my god I want to go watch
it and I was sitting next to a family
who decide to bring their like
six-month-old baby who was crying
throughout what are you doing they're 1c
is so bad and they can have a babysitter
so that [ __ ] this noise we're seeing it
yes you know good for them my buddy Phil
there's the woman brought her kid who
was like 6-7 to some [ __ ] r-rated
Foca walks down goes excuse me ma'am
this part he'd seen the movie this part
you have to cover using the child life
he's such a good guy was like what just
please trust me on this she didn't was
just this is this your favorite one yet
this was my favorite one pubis and then
I think thor ragnarok is my second
favorite people have that G like black
panther blocker is good that's like
number three is like Green Hornet Green
Hornet
sethro yeah I love that one the Green
Lantern agree was Green Hornet Green
Lantern Ryan Reynolds mm and that one's
bad that one's backing Green Hornet's
dope people hated it I thought it's good
or what that famous Asian guy to that I
didn't know some check Chinese got dug
it it was fun people hate it though
right skinny who played the original
Asian guy Bruce linear is playing sir
any other stupid question do you see I
know seven agents that's right and he's
to earn their that it dudes that's it
all right well there we are
there you are dude there you have it
people there you have it Brian are you
on the road this weekend I am down the
roast weekend I am on the road in Miami
yeah this weekend off mythic enough but
it's nice yeah it's nice may 9 10 11
Miami Orlando a club row 17 and 18 get
your tickets both improv then I got
Indianapolis June 6 7 & 8
look at that Miami all that though Miami
in Annapolis no Miami I'm looking
forward to yeah Miami you dig
I'm Florida same time you're there I'm
in Tampa though there you go
Tampa improv May 10th and 11th that's
next Friday and Saturday then after I'm
in Cleveland hilarities Cleveland May 30
through June first get your tickets now
tea fat K dot-com it B's Tuesday me and
Nick Swardson Hong Kong and I think
there are some tickets left
boom get them this fun kid route